I'd say that I miss him and I'm sorry
that I didn't appreciate him more while
he was here there is so much he wanted
to say but the shock of losing a brother
a twin has stopped him until now I want
the truth
down to every single second
up until now of what has happened who's
made the decisions who made the
decisions who allowed her to do this who
allowed all of this happened whether it
was one person at the top or a hundred
people down the whole line who decided
this was okay
because they need to be shown for it and
they need to be punished for it it's not
okay it's not fair
Niles brother Harry done died in a
collision with American driver and
sakulos she claimed
diplomatic immunity because of her
husband's job and left the country
Harry's family have never accepted that
she was entitled to it and have begun a
legal fight against the Foreign Office
who say she was I suspect you've never
really heard of the term diplomatic
immunity had you until now it was like
just punch in the face really tell me
well tough you know it's not coming back
end of story go and cry our home that's
really really what it did feel like if
you got the opportunity to get your
point across to answer Kunis and have
you thought about what you might want to
say to her this all could have been
avoided if you had just stayed here and
done the right thing and although that
time has passed you can still put an end
to all of this just by coming and
helping us the US says answer khulus is
going nowhere so the family will pursue
a civil claim for damages against her
that's all I want I want justice for my
parents because right now I can't see it
from our own point of view I just see my
mom around she deserves justice I see my
dad he deserves the truth they think
they've been let down by the authorities
on both sides of the Atlantic but
they're buoyed by public support and the
aim of bringing about change so that no
other family suffers like this Lita Dowd
sky news Northamptonshire